so I have the function f of X here and
we're defining it using a polynomial
expression and what I would like to do
here is take the derivative of our
function which is essentially going to
make us take a derivative of this
polynomial expression and we're going to
take the derivative with respect to X so
the first thing I'm going to do is let's
take the derivative of both sides so we
could say the derivative with respect to
X of f of X of f of X is equal to the
derivative with respect to X the
derivative with respect to X of x to the
fifth X to the fifth plus two plus two x
to the third minus x squared and so the
notation just to get familiar with it
you could view this as the derivative
operator this says look I want to take
the derivative of whatever is inside of
the parenthesis with respect to X so the
derivative of F with respect to X we
could use the notation that that is just
F prime of F prime of X and that is
going to be equal to now here we can use
our derivative properties the derivative
of the sum or difference of a bunch of
things is just the derivative of is
equal to the sum or the difference of D
of the derivative of each of them so
this is equal to the derivative let me
just it's the derivative with respect to
X of each of these three things so the
derivative with respect to X let me just
write it out like this of that first
term plus the derivative with respect to
X of that second term minus the
derivative with respect to X of that
third term of that third term and I'll
color code it here so here I had an X to
the fifth so I'll put the X 2/5 X to the
fifth there here I had a 2x here I had a
2x to the third so I'll put the two X to
the third
there and here I have a x squared I'm
subtracting an x squared so I'm
subtracting the derivative with respect
to X of x squared so notice all that's
happening here is I'm taking the
derivative individually of each of these
terms that I'm
adding or subtracting them the same way
that the terms were added or subtracted
and so what is this going to be equal to
well this is going to be equal to 4x to
the fifth we can just use the power rule
we can bring the five out front and
decrement the exponent by one so it
becomes 5x we could say to the five
minus one power which of course is just
four and then for this second one we
could we could do it in a few steps
actually let me just write it out here
so I could write I could write the
derivative with respect to X of 2x to
the third power is the same thing it's
equal to the same we could bring the
constant out the derivative with two
times the derivative with respect to X
of X to the third power this is one of
our this is one of our derivative
properties the derivative of a constant
times some expression is the same thing
as the constant times the derivative of
that expression and what will the
derivative with respect to X of X 1/3 be
well we would bring the 3 out front and
decrement the exponent and so this would
be equal to this 2 times the 3 times X
to the 3 minus one power which is of
course the second power so this would
give us 6x squared so another way that
you could have done it I could just
write I could just write a 6x squared
here so I could just so this is going to
be 6x squared and instead of going
through all of this you'll learn as you
do more of these that you could have
done this
pretty much in your head saying look I
have the 3 out here as an exponent let
me multiply the 3 times this coefficient
because that's what we ended up doing
anyway 3 times the coefficient is 6x and
then 3 minus 1 is 2 so you didn't
necessarily have to do this but it's
nice to see that this comes out of the
derivative properties that we talked
about in other videos and then finally
we have minus and we use the
the power rule right over here so bring
the two out front and decrement the
exponent so it's going to be two it's
going to be two times X to the two minus
one power which is just one which we
could just write us 2x so just like that
we have been able to figure out the
derivative of f and you might say well
what is this thing now well now we have
an expression that tells us the slope of
the tangent line or you could view it as
the instantaneous rate of change with
respect to X for any for any x value so
if I were to say if I were to now to say
F prime let's say F prime of two this
would tell me what is the slope of the
tangent line of our function when X is
equal to two and I do that by using this
expression so this is going to be five
times two to the fourth plus plus six
times two squared
six times 2 squared minus minus 2 times
2 minus two times two and this is going
to be equal to let's see 2 to the 4th
power is 16 16 times 5 is 80 so that's
80 and then this is 6 times 4 which is
24 and then we are going to subtract 4
so this is 80 plus 24 is 104 minus 4 is
equal to 100 so when X is equal to 2
this curve is really steep the slope is
100 that if you look if you were to
graph the tangent line when X is equal
to 2 for every ink for every positive
movement in the X direction by 1 you're
going to move up in the Y direction by a
hundred so it's really steep there and
it makes sense this is a pretty high
degree X to the fifth power and then
we're adding that to another high degree
X to the third power and then we're
subtracting a lower degree so it's what
you would expect